aquí tenemos la gráfica de la función de
igual a x elevada a la tres medios y lo
que quiero hacer es obtener la longitud
de arco desde que x es igual a cero
hasta que x es igual a voy a tomar un
número raro pues en ocasiones los
números raros nos funcionan muy bien
entonces voy a tomar la longitud de arco
desde que x es igual a cero hasta que x
es igual a 32 novenos 32 novenos vamos a
ubicar 32 novenos 32 novenos equivale a
tres enteros cinco novenos tres enteros
y un poquito más que la mitad más o
menos por aquí estaría 32 novenos
entonces lo que queremos calcular es
esta longitud de arco esta longitud que
estoy poniendo en amarillo desde que x
es igual a cero hasta que quise es igual
a 32 novenos te invito a que le pongas
pausa al vídeo e intentes hacerlo por tu
cuenta
supongo que ya lo intentaste y si en
cualquier momento te sientes inspirado
como para concluir el problema ponle
pausa y concluye lo por tu cuenta así es
vamos a aplicar la fórmula de longitud
de arco que desarrollamos de manera
conceptual sin el rigor matemático usual
en el vídeo anterior
así es que sabemos que la longitud de
arco la longitud de arco es igual a la
integral definida desde que x es igual a
cero hasta que x es igual a 32 novenos
no pensándolo bien voy a poner la
fórmula general para que puedas ver cómo
la aplicamos a nuestro ejemplo entonces
es la integral desde hasta ve de la raíz
cuadrada de 1 más
efe prima de x elevada al cuadrado de x
en nuestro caso es igual a la integral
desde que x es igual a cero hasta que x
es igual a 32 novenos de la raíz
cuadrada de 1 más la derivada de f cuál
es la derivada de fcf de x es igual a x
a la tres medios f prima de x es igual a
tres medios
elevada a la un medio y esta función la
hemos escogido a propósito así pues
cuando la sustituimos aquí dentro del
radical la expresión se simplifica de
tal manera que la anti derivada se
obtiene fácilmente así es que hemos
hecho mucha ingeniería en este problema
para que los números nos funcionen
perfectamente entonces
efe prima de x elevada al cuadrado efe
prima de x elevada al cuadrado es igual
a 9 cuartos de x así es que aquí es uno
más nueve cuartos de x de x ya tenemos
entonces la integral definida y ya
sabemos cómo encontrar la anti derivada
de esto
podrías hacerla mentalmente básicamente
haciendo la sustitución no tienes 19
cuartos de x la derivada es 9 cuartos y
así manipular el integrando de manera
adecuada pero aquí vamos a desarrollar
el proceso de sustitución así es que
haciendo la sustitución tenemos que y es
igual a 1 + 9 cuartos de x con lo cual
deben de x la derivada de v con respecto
a x de wen de x
es igual a nueve cuartos o lo que es lo
mismo
dv es igual a nueve cuartos de equis o
despejando de equis despejando de equis
aquí multiplicó por cuatro novenos ambos
lados para obtener que de x es igual a
cuatro novenos
dv cuatro novenos dv veamos ahora los
límites de integración cuando x es igual
a cero cuando x es igual a cero
es igual a uno más nueve cuartos por 0
10 es igual a 1 y ahora cuando x es
igual a 32 novenos cuando x es igual a
32 novenos veamos por qué escogimos ese
valor es igual a 1 más 9 cuartos por 32
novenos esto es 132 cuartos 18 es igual
a 9 estupendo como ves así es que esto
es igual a la integral definida de hecho
deja de poner claramente que esto es
igual a esto la integral definida desde
que y es igual a 1 hasta que es igual a
9 y aquí he puesto claramente que ahora
nuestra variable integraciones
de la raíz cuadrada de eeuu y en vez de
x tenemos nueve cuartos de déu deja de
poner lo mejor de otra manera entonces
la raíz cuadrada hauts-de-seine es el
color adecuado la raíz cuadrada
dv y en vez de de equis tenemos cuatro
novenos
dv voy a sacar cuatro novenos fuera del
integral cuatro novenos
dv y aquí por supuesto ya sabemos
aplicar el teorema fundamental del
cálculo el segundo teorema fundamental
del cálculo para resolver esta integral
definida esto es igual a cuatro novenos
que multiplica a la anti derivada de la
raíz cuadrada de eeuu que es lo mismo
que a la un medio la anti derivada de un
medio es igual a elevada tres medios
entre tres medios que podemos poner como
dos tercios y esto evaluado entre o
igual a nueve y un igual a uno y aquí ya
estamos en la recta final esto es igual
a cuatro novenos
que multiplica a ver vamos a evaluar
esto de aquí dos tercios por nueve
elevado a la tres medios menos dos
tercios que multiplica a uno elevado a
la tres medios y aquí tenemos que nueve
a la tres medios es la raíz cuadrada de
nueve estrés elevado al cubo tres al
cubo es 27 y esto por supuesto es 1 y
esto nos queda como dos tercios que
multiplica a de hecho mejor vamos a
factorizar dos tercios para facilitar
las cosas
así es que esto nos va a quedar como dos
tercios por cuatro novenos es igual a 8
sobre 27 únicamente factor izado el dos
tercios y aquí nos queda 27 menos uno
digamos dentro de los corchetes nos
queda 27 menos uno que es igual a 26
esto nos queda 8 sobre 27 por 26 y por
supuesto este resultado lo podemos
simplificar más calcular cuánto es 8 por
26 sobre 27 de hecho vamos a hacer esto
simplemente para divertirnos
esto es igual entonces veamos 8 por 20
168 por 6 48 160 más 48 208 sobre 27 y
así y así hemos concluido